I'm gonna name some people and you just
give me your impression of them okay
okay uh you said you having something
with hotep Jesus okay what is what is
your thing there oh hotep
um
you know I yeah I I kind of and
see I don't want to start I don't want
to start beef
um he's cool guy cool guy um he's always
tweeting about me like grifter or
whatever and I'm just like yeah you
don't deserve my fire tweets like he he
didn't seem acrimonious at all when he
interviewed you so why is what do you
think this this hat came from no he was
kind of a bit when he interviewed me
yeah I I just thought he was trying to
get like a gotcha moment like in the
interview I don't know it's interesting
because I kind of thought like we all go
into interviews like trying to have a
conversation and what I realized is a
lot of people are going into interviews
like trying to get a 30-second like buzz
clip or like or they're very like like
they Their audience thinks one thing and
if they go against Their audience or are
nice to you like I didn't realize it was
kind of like like that uh where because
I'm just like I came in trying to have a
convo so that was kind of how I took it
but you know just just mainly he's
tweeting that you're a grifter yeah and
I just thought it was just you know I
don't really have a strong opinion on
him either way I just felt like he
didn't deserve my fire tweets anymore
Nick Fuentes no he's a nice guy yeah um
he's a nice guy um I think he's got some
crazy opinions but yeah he was he was
very nice on the show on on a scale of
crazy opinions which do you think is the
craziest and could you rank him oh gosh
because he here's what I see when I see
now yeah I see like and I see the same
thing with Alex Jones and a bunch of
other people where it's like like 80
percent of the time somewhere between 50
and 80 of the time they're saying these
rational things that like follow along
with like moderate conservatism and
you're like oh that sounds great that
sounds like a great idea and then it's
like and then the races shouldn't mix
and I'm like oh wait a second I agreed
with everything else he said wait should
I just agree with this also am I also a
white supremacist yeah it's like he just
take it's a sales technique by the way
if you don't know this this is a common
sales technique you get a bunch of yeses
well you know I think women should be
more moral I think we should go along
with the Bible it's like man that guy's
making a lot of sense and then he just
breaks off with the [__] crazy [__]
yeah and you're like oh [__] this is the
part where you're asking for my credit
card you're not going to join you with
the white supremacy got it okay yeah oh
the Holocaust didn't happen no it's just
all those dudes just disappeared they
just went up in an alien spaceship got
it well and a lot of the stuff he was
talking about I didn't really know like
have I studied the freaking Holocaust no
I don't know
um so I mean number one that's probably
the craziest one
um two is the race mixing stuff but it
sounded really similar the stuff Dr Umar
says I mean it's I've heard that before
from like the older generation you know
it's not my opinion but yeah it's
probably the interview that's probably
the two big ones he it's really funny
because it's really [__] up so I don't
agree with the oh oh and he's Pro he
believes in like I've never met anyone
that's a fan of Stalin yeah I was like
yeah that was crazy yeah that's the
whole thing yeah yeah so that maybe
Stalin would be two I don't know Joseph
Stalin was so [__] stupid that at one
point when the German Army got all the
way to within two kilometers of the
Kremlin he had an intelligence officer
come to him and say you know uh chairman
we you know the Germans are here we have
to do something about it he had the man
tortured
for telling him the truth
that's how [__] dumb this guy was yes
dude you guys want to go to Stalin we
can go into Stalin but the thing is I I
haven't watched enough Nick points did
you see what happens to me in interviews
yeah you'll say this right and then
they'll be like Pearl push back I don't
yeah I don't know here's the thing with
with with with Nick this is what I've
seen and by the way I am not qualified
to speak on Nick Fuentes because I've
just seen a couple of Clips yeah he
feels to me like
if I was going to draw the conservative
that liberals would use to fight against
conservatives if that makes any sense
yeah if they were going to point out a
specific conservative to use as the
spokesperson to why all conservatism is
wrong and I don't feel as a conservative
I'm slightly right of Center I don't
feel like he represents me so when I
hear him I feel like he's almost a
caricature of a white supremacist does
that make sense like he's almost like a
draw like a Rick and Morty drawing of
what a white supremacist is supposed to
look like rather than actually being a
white supremacist it's kind of weird I
don't know yeah I don't like I feel like
he's I feel like he's two hairs away
from telling me the Earth is flat like
that's what it feels like with me
because if it got him more views I feel
like he'd say that he doesn't believe
that I I don't you know that flat
earthers get their beliefs from The Book
of Genesis it says that there's a
firmament over us that's what they get
it from I don't know yeah I'm not into I
don't know about that but he's he's a
nice guy he's actually he's a smart guy
Jesus is super nice is Gary grinsberg
the [__] uh Gary the numbers guy so
[__] nice to ask me now to go to
dinner afterwards yeah and then he just
says this like horrible stuff on there
yeah basically like I don't even want to
get into the the the main parts of it
but like it's one of these things where
I understand that people will say a
couple of things like I'll give you an
example man I listen to Candace Owens
and she says a bunch of things I'm like
oh I agree with what you're saying I
still I don't think it was relevant that
George Floyd committed crimes before
somebody murdered him like why are you
who gives a [__] like why are you
bringing this up as a conservative I'm
just like I don't understand why you're
doing this so it's like one of these
things where I agree with that I agree
with that I can get 10 15 things that I
agree with and then you go off the rails
on this one thing where it's like you
are looking for support on White lives
matter which I'm fine with but then
you're using Kanye West as sort of like
to help you with this whole thing when
he openly has a mental disorder that was
one of the things where I had a big
problem with the Kanye thing is like
Kanye's admitting Kanye has a mental
disorder and now we're holding him up to
the light being like this is an example
of what we need to follow and his
viewpoints are valid I'm like wait can
we just back up and use somebody else
besides the dude who who admits to
getting off his medication can we use
somebody else that's the part that I
think is just kind of like irresponsible
you see what I'm saying
yeah I I don't know
um
I think
I don't know if I think Kanye is crazy
or not but he said he's crazy like Kanye
is a frequently yeah but he's also said
that like he's tired of people saying
that he's crazy when he's like gifted
like I don't know I I don't really want
to yeah he also said slavery was a
choice you know I'm not I'm definitely
not speaking about that comment keep me
out of that one yeah yeah uh but I don't
know maybe I'm wrong maybe when I listen
to listen to like full stuff like I
understand what he's trying to say no I
understand what he's trying to say I get
it too but I I also think he has a
cluster B personality disorder yeah
that's the issue and like the thing is
can we use we're using extreme examples
on both sides like AOC is an extreme
extreme example I think there's liberals
who are way more middle of the road and
like understand Concepts better than her
right men should not be competing in
women's sports that's ridiculous like
there's no there's no counter argument
to that and then like but then you see
this like this is an extreme example
can't we be like a little bit more
moderate and have a conversation because
if we can't there's no conversation to
be had well I think that's the problem
with media to be honest is that like
people just become so beholden to their
audiences
yeah so they have to be extreme and they
can't like talk about Nuance but I think
Kanye is an example of that and he
doesn't he says I love Hitler that's not
nuanced that's that's true that's being
a shocker I mean I don't think he does
that for his audience wait but he just
says things
that's mental illness yeah I mean I just
I don't really see it but you know okay
that's my opinion yeah okay yeah
um even Alex Jones is like what the [__]
anyway that's why
um the other thing I was going to talk
to you about uh so I I would love for
you and Rolo to be able to sit down and
like I don't know what the [__]
problem is I kind of understand what do
you think the issue was where you guys
would go back and forth what do you
think it came from
back and forth not back and forth I did
not I did not respond what did I respond
you didn't respond to anything I said
yeah yeah
um and then I'm gonna tell you what I
think it is
um
this is a
when when we started he was really
helpful to me and my set yes and so he
was helping me with stuff and like he
was giving me advice
um I start to blow up
um and I was trying to get him to like
Mentor me sure and I think like like I
was saying I would pay him for his time
and like because I really I really
looked up to him like honestly I thought
like he was so smart and like I just
really loved his stream yeah
um and then he basically like he
basically
um he went on this like podcast and then
was like oh Pearl I forgot I don't
remember what he said it really hurt my
feelings though to be honest
um like she's oh she's a hack or
something and like and I was like ah I
thought okay you know
um his exact words to me because we had
a conversation about it is that she he
said the same thing he thought you were
hacked but he didn't dislike you it was
just one of these situations let me talk
I'll talk after you finish if you finish
saying what you're saying
um yeah and so then
um
yeah and that
uh I'm like trying to remember I don't
even remember what happened next but he
would just always tweet about me and I'm
just like why are we why are we tweeting
isn't this a bit of mature like why do
you think he felt that way
um he he calls me an idiot all the time
so yeah there's a little too much what
but what what do you why do you think he
and I immediately got along
well I mean he's been doing this stuff
for like 20 years yeah so I read
probably somewhere between 40 and 60
books a year oh wow there's nothing like
he's the only human I've met in my life
who reads as much on evolutionary
psychology as me and that includes phds
the reason why we got together and why
it works so much even though we disagree
on certain things like he's he's like I
would never vote for a female politician
I'm like no the lady who runs Las Vegas
is pretty awesome she was trying to get
us back to work during the pandemic she
did a [__] awesome job there's some
exceptions okay
or in in his case where he talks about
like men and women could be friends that
was a big debating point for when we
first when we first met right yeah but
because we kept this thing
evidence-based he and I got along really
well God famously and the other thing is
when I presented evidence to him like I
took him to my birthday party and there
were 50 girls there and they were all
just like we love Michael and then like
he saw the girls I was dating and all
this kind of stuff he was like oh okay I
see this now okay now I didn't see it
this way now I see this and he was open
to this idea that's why it worked the
thing is and this is what I asked him I
was like hey if Pearl red you know
anybody wants to take notes on these if
Pearl red
the ape that understood the universe by
Steven Stuart Williams and pearl red the
evolution of Desire by David Buss and
pearl red why women have sex by David
bus and Sydney Mason and pearl red
um when men behave badly by David Buss
and pearl red mate by Joffrey Wilson and
Paul red
um any of the books by Stephen Pinker or
Gad sad and pearl red why beautiful
people have more daughters by Satoshi
kanazawa do you think Zen you would
still think she's a hacking he's like no
it's like at that point she would have
done the work that's a that's an extreme
microcosm but she would have done the
work in order to have a conversation on
what that's what he that's what Rolo and
I don't want to put words in his mouth
and frolo disagrees with me he can he
can tweet and say some or do super chat
or say something we'll read it
but for Rolo what he respects is that
people follow the evidence
when you had Nick Fuentes on and got you
know yelled at because of it you know
whatever semi-cancel whatever all the
controversy and then you said you didn't
know who he was Pearl do you understand
I did 30 hours of study before you came
on here today right I can't I I don't I
only have 50 000 Subs I have to do tons
of work before someone comes on and it
felt like in your situation you were
talking about a lot of these things from
anecdotal stuff I love when you start
talking about 40 of women have had two
abortions that's you quoting statistics
that's great but like for for him in his
standpoint what he admires I'll tell you
right now is the work the study that's
going I'll give you those six books I
compared until you read those oh last
one's alphagot by Hector Garcia if you
read those books I promise you he'd be
like okay now she's taking these ideas
from the concept of evolutionary studies
as a pro as opposed to you understand
when you just start saying things based
on how you feel how are you any
different from the view or [__] Dr
Phil the the reason why we have no
respect for those people as content
creators is because they're just spewing
either a political woke rhetoric or
they're just talking about their [__]
feelings and for the reason why he
respects Myron for instance is because
Myron reads a ton you see what I'm
saying that's what I'm not saying you're
right or wrong I'm just telling you
that's what the way he would express it
maybe he didn't do a good enough job
expressing it and I'm not blaming you
I'm just saying because I want to see
the two of you work together to be
honest with you but that's what I would
say I don't know if you think that's
fair
um
yeah okay
that makes sense
because I support I think the stuff you
do is great that's just where I'm coming
from
um yeah I just
yeah
um I mean I think that he could have
said that to me instead of going online
and I just think it's kind of immature
and I I think it's really unprofessional
to every time you have an issue with
someone tweet about it
um instead of like that was a
conversation that could have maybe been
had behind the scenes right
um
and so here's the thing he I talked to
him about it yeah and I was like I think
you should work with her and then he
said you guys were talking on the phone
and then you did a live stream and then
he felt that Nick Fuentes just showing
up on the [__] stream that he was on
was a little unprofessional do you
understand yeah and then and then I
looked for it and you would pull that
stream down well yeah because I I did it
because he was like I thought he was mad
so that's why I pulled it because like
for him like yeah so like I was like oh
[__] I think I think he thinks that you
pulled it because Nick Fuentes I said
crazy [__] yeah no that's the first time
I've heard that no no I did it because
for like because I thought Rolo was mad
yeah like I thought he was mad and I was
like oh [__] like I didn't mean to like
I don't know okay but he doesn't like
believe me so like okay yeah my whole
thing is that now look at it from Two
standpoints and the first standpoint
you you from his standpoint you said
you're an Entertainer that's why I don't
hold this against you you're saying
you're an Entertainer from his
standpoint he felt like you didn't do
the work again Rolo if I'm saying stuff
you don't agree with please like like
chime in
he felt like you didn't do the work I
just gave you seven eight books to read
okay
and additionally when you have Nick
Fuentes on the first time and people are
offended you say you didn't know that
this was gonna happen you didn't do
enough research like I said well I'm
having Patrick by David on in August I
will do I'm not kidding 50 hours on him
I will spend two three weeks just
studying up to he was in the hundred
first Airborne I have nothing but
respect for the man
and so I didn't say I didn't know who he
was I said I didn't like know all of
what he did and so like sometimes like I
feel like and sometimes and I and I
think this is fair I can do that on my
own Channel that I built right now wait
wait so I have like the right to bring
someone on and if I don't want like
because I think that sometimes like you
go into an interview you already know
everything about the person like I think
what I really like I'm bringing on
YouTube is having a conversation like
that you would have behind the scenes
that's like in good faith yeah and I
feel like when when you bring on someone
that's like canceled if you know every
like bad thing they've said ever
whatever like I just wanted like to go
in with like an open mind and that's
what I was talking about and I just
think it's like okay if you don't like
it then do something else on your your
show for sure yeah I think it's a valid
Viewpoint I'm just trying to explain to
you what maybe where he's coming from
and obviously yeah I wish he was having
this conversation with you yeah but
that's where it happened so but the
thing is it's the first time with Nick
and then it happens again when he's on
the show that all of a sudden Nick shows
up I'm by the way I'm not trying to do a
doctor I want you two to work together
no well I mean with with Rolo I mean I
told him that I was going to invite
content creators on yeah and like that's
and so I thought it was fine yeah and
and then yeah and then he's he's super
like and I was like oh [__] like the
only reason I pulled the stream was
because like because of like because
um some someone messaged me during the
stream and was like that this isn't good
or whatever yeah and I was just like oh
oh [__] and so that was why I pulled for
sure I understand yeah yeah it's just
but again it's like it's kind of like
why are we having this conversation on a
live like now you know when we we could
have had this like yeah yeah yeah listen
I'm I'm trying to be yeah Jimmy Carter
here yeah trying to bring the people
together so I mean I've always been a
fan of Rolo and I just feel like no
matter like it's very immature to always
go to Twitter and always like posting
every time you have an issue and a lot
of this stuff like I think it kind of
makes the space look bad as a whole to
be honest when you're like doing this
yeah we also I wanted you you probably
figure this out we have very different
personalities yeah if you had done that
to me I would be like [__] yes I would
have been excited and that's why I told
role I was like I would I want half of
me on some time surprise and [__] have
three of my exes and [__] you know
some more criminals yeah I'm gonna
because I'm different I'm just I'm just
different like that but I think in his
his standpoint with Rolo it's not just a
question of his
um like the number of followers he has
yeah there's a level of credibility he
has because of the books and so whenever
he goes on someone's show he feels he's
lending that credibility to that person
does that make sense so he lends in his
mind he lends The credibility again roll
if I'm saying something you disagree
with let me know yeah he's lending that
credibility to you and then you turn
around and it's Nick Fuentes you see
what I'm saying and Rollo no and I
understood why he was mad like I
apologize like immediately yeah like I
was like oh my gosh I'm so sorry like I
pulled the stream because I was I was
just like oh God like I was like gosh
I'm so stupid like I was literally after
the stream yeah I was on the phone I was
just like I am a freaking idiot pulled
it was done and I but it's like I can't
like when he's constantly thinking I'm
like out to get him or whatever it's
just like it's it's I know you guys like
that you guys had the whole 21 like
whatever like that whole like not maybe
not you but everyone in the manosphere
had that like big beef or whatever where
people were turning on each other but
it's like oh the 21 convention yes
and I don't really know what happened
with it but it's like I feel like I'm
getting punished for something I didn't
do yeah and so it's like like I've
genuinely he's called me an idiot on
stream he's caught like he he has said
like things that are so rude when
literally I have only been trying like I
just wanted him to Mentor me yeah and if
he sat me down and said oh read this
book read this book like I probably
would have had like
yeah and so um like he said something to
me about reading his book religion and
then I read it like so I don't know yeah
well I'm an audiobook person I'm sorry I
know you guys are no no he's already he
actually I think he makes more money
from the audiobooks yeah yeah I think
that's great so
um yeah I didn't even have an issue with
him being like mad about the the second
time I was like okay that was stupid
you're right yeah and yeah but then it's
like he runs to Twitter yeah it's just
like and it's it's like immature like
when it's like I'm the I'm the girl I'm
I'm not the one tweeting
right sorry that was rude I shouldn't I
should have said that something don't
worry about it I mean I just I wanted
you and again I I don't know what the
whole thing is we've had a couple of
conversations about this I'm of the
opinion I would like all of us to be
able to work together it's crazy like
some of these beefs but the thing is I
don't come from the red pill Community
yeah I come from that Community yeah you
see what I'm saying well I would too
I've wanted nothing but to like work
with him yeah like genuinely
um but it's like I can't
it's like I can only do so much you know
so yeah uh Destiny what do you think
about Destiny
um Destiny's fine yeah yeah
I found him uh I actually was worried
about him like like I said before making
like a bunch of ad hominem attacks I
actually really enjoyed debating yeah no
Destiny's Destiny's all right um I would
actually like for us to find something
we agree on and then debate against
other people I would like to do that
with him because I you know obviously we
don't see the things the same way yeah
it's really interesting because like I'm
not bisexual nobody's touching my
[__] girl like that's not happening
and he finds it that he finds that to be
acceptable and so he loses credibility
with red pill people because of that
whole situation and I think they
shouldn't really attack him for what he
does like it doesn't really matter what
he does in his personal life yeah I
could be honest
um yeah but yeah Destiny's fine yeah
what from what I understood he spent
before we did the debate he didn't
stream for two days and from my
understanding he was preparing because
he was going to go up against Rollo yeah
and Rolo is just like a [__] fountain
or just a just a exactly that was a
great debate yeah that was great
encyclopedia pretend like he even blows
me away bro he comes up with [__] and
like I really try to keep up in this one
Arena I I have a hard time keeping up
with him and this is what this is my
thing you know what I'm saying and so
that's the thing that's so impressive
I'm just explaining to you that is what
Rolo respects more than anything yeah
the people who put in the work
intellectually and that's also why like
he's not as politically conservative as
some of the other people in the space
and that's generally when you when you
just stick to the facts you find that
that tends to be the case does it make
sense
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible